mais pourquoi vous passez qui sont tout
le temps malade les enfants la moisson
mais la bouffe qui traînent partout
quand il est fâché
on n'intervient pas physiquement
romain salin koudache non plus je le
comprends pas la consommation de
cannabis et extrêmes
le bureau la fontaine est en plein coeur
de schlager jeunesse au soleil qui a
donné la maison à la dpj
on a entouré à peu près de 180 dossiers
à gérer d'enfants donc de chris kaman is
santé mentale est un problème évidemment
de négligence et le jonway de nos
situations
c'est ici que les intervenants en
protection de la jeunesse
suivent les enfants les plus vulnérables
du quartier moi je pouvais pas
m'imaginer que ça se passe à côté de
shing même encore après 14 assez
surprenant de voir la misère et la
détresse
claudine fait partie des dix huit
intervenants du bureau
aujourd'hui je m'en rends concret une
famille qui a je suis c'est des parents
qui ont une grande crainte de la
protection de la jeunesse quand même que
ça fait pas nécessairement leur affaire
qu'on soit l'autre c'est qu'en général à
chaque fois qu'il jugeait sur place le
papa n'est pas content pendant les 15
premières minutes de l'entrevue il me le
fait ressentir
à chaque fois je suis bord de quitter
parce que j'aime pas la façon qui me
parlent mais ont fini par s'entendre ses
collègues
claudia s'occupent actuellement d'une
douzaine d'enfants âgés entre 0 et 50
des ventes
tout le monde doit cesser sont un peu
dans la même situation et tout d'aider
des parents avec des jeunes enfants qui
ont eu des problèmes de consommation qui
s'en sortent avec un programme
alternatif de méthadone suboxone nous
conclut parents sont dans des
appartements comme ça on est confiant
parce que de la surveillance en tout
temps elle a commencé la garderie la
semaine prochaine alors commencé déjà
pensé que c'était début juin
on y voit trois jours par semaine parce
que dans le fond dans lordonnance on
avait un minimum de trois jours parce
qu'elle avait ya les trois jours non
mais ça s'est bien passé
quand on voit une petite fille souriante
qui est une bonne marque et jovial qui
pour partie qui mangent la nana on se
dit bon je pense qu on a pas de raison
de s'inquiéter aujourd'hui à cette heure
là qu'est ce qui se passera demain par
contre cette vigilance le faut la garder
culte pour la garder tout le temps tu
sais c'est vraiment ça quand on
travaille avec des parents qu'ils
consomment cesser la gestion du risque
parce qu'ils peuvent être un an sont
consommées puis que ça va bien que
l'enfant se développe bien que l'ancien
fréquentent la garderie puis du jour au
lendemain on appelle la police mesures
d'urgence l'enfant il sortit de sa
maison tout seul parce que les deux
parents étaient complètement gelé sur
des substances
ce matin marianne a rendu visite à une
petite qui a été placé en foyer
d'accueil sur la rive sud
j'avais quand même presqu'une heure et
demie de route à faire
j'ai déjà eu une famille de trois
enfants qui avaient été placés en
famille d'accueil j'avais une famille
d'accueil sur la rive sud
une autre famille d'accueil sur la
rive-nord j'avais une autre famille
était complètement dans l'ouest de
montréal
avec la pénurie de famille d'accueil à
montréal il faut souvent placé les
enfants dans des foyers à l'extérieur de
la ville
un petit a réussi on dit et on repart
cet après-midi avec deux rencontres on
va aller rencontrer une famille de sept
enfants
en fait le juge nous demande bon on a un
suivi au niveau de la négligence puis
des méthodes éducatives le déraisonnable
des hannetons bgi d'étape pour corriger
les enfants on devrait avoir douze à
quatorze suivi d'enfants
moi j'en ai 19 ils veulent faire une
entente avec vous pour le ménage pour
les traitements contre big beat là je
vois vous avez fait vous avez fait un
bon ménage c'est sûr qu'au niveau c'est
de l'état du logement de madame c'est
inquiétant on a
en fait deux enfants de madame qui sont
allergiques aux coquerel il ya une
infestation coquerel
donc il ya une amélioration mais
clairement ce salon un impact direct sur
sur la santé de deux enfants il faut
frapper ici il faut arrêter frappe il
faut pas frapper surtout rappeler ici
mais on fera pas du tout quelqu'un on
fait on la porte dans sa chambre dans un
coin calme
oui c'est pas mieux si on donne des
tapes sur les genoux la l'intervenant
est le témoin de ce qui se passe mais
viens viens viens me consulter venait
consulter la chef de service consulter
les rupteurs donc on est plusieurs à
prendre une décision je lui ai dit des
choses avec toi parce que j'ai reçu les
verbalisations de la maman et pour
l'intervenant blv pont reste toujours
avec un doute avec une hésitation pions
sur inès on est passé à côté de quelque
chose si on n'a pas vu telle chanson et
pau et on n'a pas de pouvoir de lire
dans les pensées
oui mais sa faute bon sens a fait plus
d'une semaine qui a pas de frigidaires
les parents de deux enfants de 1 et 3
ans non plus de réfrigérateurs à la
maison depuis maintenant dix jours
s'il vous plaît je pourrais parler et à
chaque fois que claudine demande aux
parades régler le problème
ils deviennent agressifs mais j'ai fait
mon but je veux pas vous poursuit jetons
vous parlez de poursuite la rencontre
sur ma tête mais je comprends lola est
ce que c'est possible de centrer sur les
bonnes chances oui je vais je vais pas
craquer je vais parfait je vais mettre
fin à l'appel une fois je pense que
c'est marc chef de service ce qui va
téléphoner à madame et monsieur pour
parce que rendu ils sont pas capables en
mesure de parler avec moi je dois
franche et après vous mais c'est sûr que
quand même blessé trois messages comme
vous vous laissez moi je voulais dire je
vous rappelle une fois par semaine pas
plus dans un autre bureau
l'intervenante audrey discute avec la
grand mère d'une jeune fille placée en
famille d'accueil
allez dans une bonne famille d'accueil
vous n'avez pas nous suivre par la
collector de superviser et l'on parle de
votre petite fille puis elle vous l'a
déjà dit
deux ans vous aviez déjà retrouvé sa
maison de famille d'accueil
allez pas aimé ça le téléphone le
discours de la grand-mère dans tous les
sens on met ça le coude h non plus je ne
comprends pas le père se serait fait
d'un coup de hache par qu'un autre
membre de la famille pour une chicane
la grand mère pense qu'on fait des tests
adn secret pour faire reconnaître le
part parce que le parent n'est pas
reconnu à tout moment les intervenants
peuvent avoir à prendre une décision qui
aura un impact sur la vie des enfants
c'est cela notre aval de la gestion du
risque de s'assurer que l'addition
comprend au moins d'impacts négatifs
possibles sur l'enfance pas toujours la
meilleure des solutions
ces serres kiki que des fois la moins
pire des fois les deux juges voient pas
les choses la même façon que nous
ordonnons autre chose on a aussi à vivre
avec si ces ordonnances là qui dévoient
fond de sens et d'autres fois pour nous
un peu moins qui c'est certain que c'est
confrontant pour vous c'est confrontant
pour monsieur l'après midi avance
l'histoire du frigo semble loin d'être
réglée finalement il y aura pas de frigo
aujourd'hui qui va arriver demain car il
va arriver vous mettre les quand même ne
serait pas mon bureau mais vous nous
laisse un message dit qu'un vous né
serez le message pour me dire c'est beau
en ahl frigo je n'ai pas s'ils venaient
vous voir ben ouais même la fin de
semaine durant le week-end kim s'est
assuré que le frigo avait bien été
livrés et que l'appartement était en
meilleur état
il mène après des années d année on en
reste quand même un truc un peu
bouleversé d'heure de ce qu'on peut voir
ce qu'on peut être témoin
ouais ouais mais c'est un beau métier
quand même poule donne souvent l'exemple
d'un petit garçon que j'ai suivi pied se
défont c'est vrai viendront pas au
médecin qui viendront peau et fabrique
des fois non mais cet enfant là qui
avait d'énormes difficultés
un jour j'étais allé le voir piment de
sondages under qui avait eu des verts
toute la semaine et qu'ils quittent et
qui était tellement content pipeline
marche maintenant km victoire avec soin
brut révèle malgré tout temps des petits
nés rares etc
les petites choses comme ça il faut se
rattacher à six mois
[Rires]